to cat a z so we can get rid of the ZF operation and now using the description
of cat U that we have up here along with the fact that K a0 and K A1 are orthogonal unit vectors we can compute
the product of this bra right here and this cat and what we get is the square root of the number of nons Solutions
divided by n we can use this fact to evaluate what we get and by substituting in our expression for cat U and
simplifying we get the final result that's shown here on the screen in particular notice that this
Vector is contained in the two-dimensional Subspace span by K a0 and K A1 as I suggested before and
moreover the coefficients happen to be real numbers as always verify this at your
own pace if you choose to do that I tend to go through these sorts of things quickly in these videos with the
expectation that you'll pause the video to give it some thought if you choose to do that so let's clean this up so that
we can save the final result for later and now we'll do something similar for the vector k
A1 we can use the same expression of G as before and this time the ZF gate injects
a minus sign which here is reflected by the fact that we've swapped the two terms in the operation in
parenthesis we then proceed in a very similar way and the final result is similar except that the two coefficients
are swapped and we now have a minus sign in front of one of them which is just how the algebra works out and again you
can check this at your own pace notice that once again we have a real linear combination of our two vectors K a0 and
K A1 we'll clean this one up as well and we'll put the end result together with the other one and now we can see how G
acts on the Subspace spanned by our two vectors one way to do that is to express it in terms of the 2x2 matrix M that's
shown here on the screen and just to be clear what we're doing here is we're associating the first row and the First
Column with K a0 and the second row and column with Kat A1 so far in the series we we really
just used matrices to describe the way that operations work on standard basis States but it is common to use matrices
to describe the actions of linear maps on different sets of vectors not just standard basis States and here we're talking about what the operation G does
to the vectors K a0 and K A1 we can say more about what G does to vectors in the
span of K a0 and K A1 if we take a closer look at this Matrix M and in particular what we'll find is
that m is a rotation Matrix meaning that its action on this two-dimensional space can be described as a rotation by some
fixed angle there are a couple of different ways to see this and one is to observe
that this Matrix M can be expressed as the square of a matrix that looks somewhat simpler that might be hard to spot if
we're just looking at M by itself but this isn't something that we need to discover on our own we just need to verify it and we can do that by simply
squaring The Matrix on the right another way to write the Matrix on the right not including the square is
shown on the screen and this is the typical way to describe a rotation by a given angle Theta as a
matrix the precise angle by which we're rotating happens to be the inverse sign of the square root of the number of
solutions divided by n and by the way because this is the first time that we're seeing it let me point out that
this angle is very important it's going to keep keep showing up as we continue with this
analysis the argument of the inverse sign is a number between 0 and 1 and specifically the way that we're
interpreting the inverse sign here is that it's the angle between 0 and Pi / 2 that gives us the argument when we take
the sign so that's one way to think about this Matrix that we squared to get
M and because squaring The Matrix is the same thing as applying it twice we see that M can alternatively be written as a
rotation not by an angle of theta but by two * Theta because by squaring we rotate by an angle of theta
twice a different way to verify all this by the way in case it's helpful is to start with this final expression of M
and use the double angle formulas from trigonometry to obtain the original expression of
M and this is the expression of M which describes the action that g has on the Subspace Spann by K a0 and K A1 that's
going to be most useful going forward now returning to Grover's algorithm itself after the
initialization step but before we perform any applications of G the state of our n Cubit register Q is Catu the
uniform superposition over all nbit strings and here we have the same expression of cat u in terms of K a0 and
K A1 as before but now that we've identified this angle Theta we see that that we
could alternatively write k u as cosine Theta * k a 0 plus sin Theta * K
A1 that's clear for the coefficient of K A1 and for the other coefficient we just need to observe that the size of a0 plus
the size of A1 is n and then we can just get it from some basic trigonometry so that's the state we
start with and the first time that we apply G we rotate by an angle of 2 * Theta so the total angle becomes 3 *
Theta and if we apply G again the angle increases to 5 Theta because we've effectively rotated by an additional
angle of 2 Theta and so on so after T applications of G we can represent the
state that we get as is shown on the screen where the angle of our state is equal to 2T + 1 * Theta that's 2 * Theta
for each application of G along with an additional Theta because that's the state we started in
we can also think about the action of the grover operation in geometric terms and this helps to shed some light on how
it works and why its effect is to rotate the state of the register Q here's the main idea the grover
operation is a composition of the two parts that we've already identified one is ZF and the other is z or send between
two layers of hadamar gates these two parts are
reflections and when we compose two Reflections we obtain a rotation so let's see how this works in
more detail first let's focus on ZF and we're going to restrict our attention to the
same two-dimensional Subspace that we've been talking about meaning the one that's spanned by cat a0 and Kat
A1 as we already observed the action of ZF on this space is quite simple it does
nothing to cat a z and it puts a minus sign in front of K A1 this is a reflection and specifically